[Musique]
Geneviève Tellier qui est avec nous ce
soir bienvenue madame Tellier Michel COG
et Christian Dufour bonsoir
bonsoir Geneviève Tellier qu'on connaît
bien sur notre réseau vous êtes inversé
d'Ottawa puis je vais d'ailleurs
commencer avec vous parce que là la
Fondation Pierre Trudeau en principe
c'est pour encourager et c'est ça dans
les faits aussi des étudiants
universitaires aller plus loin
faites-nous un petit topo rapidement sur
ce qu'est parce que là on en parle
beaucoup on oublie parfois de commencer
par le début de l'histoire
c'est une fondation qui a été créée une
vingtaine d'années pour justement elle
se présente en disant c'est pour former
les leaders de demain on veut aller
recruter des docteurs en prometteur et
on leur donne des bourses des bourses
assez généreuses je pense c'est 40 000
dollars par année pendant 3 ans et en
plus de leurs études de ces étudiants-là
vont rencontrer toutes sortes de
personnes natalités de leader vont avoir
des mentors vont participer à des
conférences et donc c'est vraiment pour
créer une nouvelle génération de de
personnes de jeunes qui s'impliqueront
plus tard dans la société et donc ça se
finance par des dons privés c'est des
fondations il faut aussi que le
gouvernement fédéral a créé elle-même a
donné des fonds qui sont en fiducides
donc c'est de l'argent placé puis les
revenus Serval justement financer les
bourses et parmi ces dons-là ce fameux
don là d'un personnage chinois dont on
parle beaucoup et c'est ça qui est au
cœur de la tourmente c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec cet argent là qu'on
devrait restituer et vous le dites bien
Geneviève Tellier c'est au cœur de la
augmente parce qu'on comprend mieux
aujourd'hui que les démissions c'est des
gens qui étaient pas d'accord avec la
façon dont gérait le remboursement ou
pas du 200 000 données par le citoyen
chinois dont le globe soupçonne qu'il a
été remboursé par l'État chinois donc
autrement dites contribution directement
de l'État chinois dans une fondation et
c'est là que
c'est là que tout ça implose Michel COG
aujourd'hui
David Johnson qui doit par ailleurs de
façon générale déterminer si une enquête
publique ou pas sur un gérant chinois
qui lui est lié à la Fondation Trudeau
l'opposition dit vous n'avez pas la
crédibilité ça rend une autre couche de
complexité là
nécessairement quelqu'un de biaiser
quelqu'un qui à cause de du fait qu'il a
été associé à la Fondation Trudeau va
pas faire un travail ou plus cela dit
comme on dit familièrement ça regarde
mal et toute cette histoire-là était un
problème
presque insoluble vous savez la
Fondation Trudeau a pas de rapport avec
le gouvernement Justin Trudeau va en
même temps faut bien certain quelqu'un
qui donne de l'argent avec cette
fondation là c'est bien que quelque part
le non Trudeau c'est le nom du premier
ministre du Canada alors mettez tout ça
ensemble c'est c'est difficile à régler
je pense que ça met une couche de plus
sur une chose la probabilité qu'on se
retrouve avec une enquête publique parce
que à la fin
si
il va avoir de démanglions comme ça plus
le public canadien quelque chose qui va
nous permettre de savoir ce qui en est
avec influence c'est une enquête
publique et là notre collègue nous
racontait c'est un peu surréaliste il y
a un huissier qui se promenait qu'un
chèque de 200000 dollars pour aller
rembourser le citoyen chinois mais là il
trouve pas puis là où il doit travailler
il travaille alors là il y a on fait
quoi avec le 200000 on le remet dans nos
coffres ou pas chicane on veut plus
d'argent là Christian il y a ça dit
beaucoup sur l'air du temps aussi là
mais bref êtes-vous d'accord avec Michel
c'est og que ça milite pour qu'il y a
une vraie enquête sur
le plus gros sujet qui laisse gérant de
chinoise oui parce qu'on pourrait penser
que c'est juste rocambolesque mais les
gens qui ont démissionné massivement
nous parlent d'intimidation de menaces
de climat toxiques et puis ce qui est
arrivé en partie c'est que le dossier à
Ottawa le gérant chinoise dans les
élections canadiennes au sujet duquel
monsieur Trudeau a beaucoup résisté en
fait à l'idée d'avoir une enquête
contaminée en fait le dossier de la
Fondation Trudeau et le Pacifique
alimente la suspicion puis la suspicion
puis ça donne évidemment des munitions
l'opposition prochainement il y a aussi
quelque chose là il y a quelque chose
qu'on sait pas qu'on va apprendre qui va
nous scandaliser ou c'est juste un écran
de fumée bon monsieur Trudeau hier
parlait des attentats de l'opposition
d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé qu'il devrait
travailler son français le des attaques
vicieuses de l'opposition là-dessus mais
là vendredi est-ce qu'on va apprendre
quelque chose le chef de cabinet
monsieur Trudeau va comparaître donc on
peut on peut prendre ça pas totalement
au sérieux mais moi je me pose la
question quand même surtout que je
sous-estime pas les Chinois il faut pas
sous-estimer les Chinois ça peut se
défendre qu'il y a identifié la
Fondation Trudeau ils sont intelligents
en voulant dire ah c'est pas
gouvernemental mais c'est quand même
presque le nom de Monsieur Trudeau mais
pas cités on le sait pas mais c'est la
vérité c'est comme c'est pas mais il y a
beaucoup de suspicion voilà vraiment
Geneviève Tellier est-ce que est-ce que
la Fondation va être tentée de passer
moi l'expression mais de repartir sur un
autre nom le dossier de tourner la page
ils vont chercher des membres pour leur
des nouveaux membres pour leur conseil
d'administration est-ce que ça vous
tente de proposer votre nom je veux
avoir tout le monde qui part comme ça
c'est étrange par contre je vais revenir
un peu sur la question de chaque pays du
huissier parce que ça me semble
important ça c'est une question que
devrait approfondir une enquête sur
l'intérêt chinoise si des donateurs
partent après quelques années dans la
brume puis on sait plus où on est
capable de retrouver il y a une question
de reddition de compte et ça je pense
qu'on voudrait savoir quoi faire avec ce
fameux chèque là bon je pense pas trop
compliqué si on est trop capable de le
donner on le donne à une autre fonction
charité peut-être ou on en fait quelque
chose c'est pas très compliqué comme
problème mais ce qui est compliqué c'est
de ne pas pouvoir retrouver la trace de
donateurs puissant effectivement je
pense qu'il y a des questions à se poser
et que le gouvernement devrait regarder
ça mais oui est-ce qu'on part sous un
autre nom peut-être ceci étant dit la
Fondation Trudeau est quand même
associée à la famille Trudeau il y a des
représentants de la succession Trudeau
qui sont dans l'organisation qui sont
membres donc on peut pas dire que c'est
complètement indépendant non plus alors
oui c'est embarrasse monsieur Trudeau
puis il va peut-être falloir changer le
fonctionnement ça c'est certain et vous
d'accord Geneviève que ça milite
vraiment c'est un argument de plus pour
lancer une enquête publique sur tout ça
c'est la chef de cabinet de ce Trudeau
et il y a une nouvelle ronde des
questions qui vient d'être créée
c'est-à-dire on va lui poser des
questions sur la Fondation Trudeau c'est
évident et à chaque fois remarquer sur
plusieurs semaines à chaque fois on a
des nouveaux éléments qui arrivent dans
les médias de quelques façons que ce
soit autour de les gérances chinoises
j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils soient
terminé rapidement on le souligne c'est
vendredi que la chef de cabinet de
Monsieur Trudeau est entendu devant ce
comité puis elle répondra aux questions
des des députés voilà un mot sur Air
Canada avant de passer au drag queen
alors on est vraiment spectre large
aujourd'hui
Air Canada avec Gérald j'ai montré le
salaire
c'est pas tellement le salaire qui
m'intéresse cette fois-ci mais on le
montre quand même c'est c'est notable
mais a-t-il appris le français on s'en
souvient ma col Russo ça a été une
grosse affaire qui a duré plusieurs
semaines
via Montréal et dit je vais m'engager
oui j'ai compris apprendre le français
la réponse courte Michel si c'est contre
le sait pas
on ne sait pas parce que il y a pas fait
de nouveau discours en chambre de
commerce pour nous montrer ses talents
c'est que le président du conseil
d'administration de Canada avait dit que
la question de la capacité de monsieur
Rousseau de s'exprimer en français
ferait partie de l'évaluation de son
dossier en vue de lui donner son salaire
alors là bon on va de bon compte ce
qu'il reçoit aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
recevait avant la pandémie puis qui est
pendant la pandémique vu que le
gouvernement fédéral payait on a dit à
ces gens-là de couper leur salaire cela
dit ça va pas bien au Canada ça fait pas
d'argent au Canada la
l'action est plus basse qu'avant la
pandémie alors est-ce qu'on est-ce que
c'est une bonne idée de lui donner ça ça
serait donc à faire mais jusqu'à preuve
du contraire il supposé prendre des
cours de français mais au nombre
d'années qui sont écoulées des gens là
ils devraient être capable de parler
français puis de pas avoir peur de
sortir
oui et Michel ce que vous êtes et
intéressant c'est que pendant la
pandémie il n'avait pas le choix
l'entreprise n'avait pas le choix
Estelle loi un règlement il ne pouvait
pas dépasser un certain montant pour le
salaire compte tenu des subventions des
prêts et des dons là ils ne sont plus
liés au gouvernement peuvent payer comme
ils veulent Geneviève Tellier mais le
Français qui revient hanté cette
entreprise
oui et ça me démontre encore que la loi
de la modernisation des langues
officielles il faut l'adopter parce que
il va y avoir des dents un peu plus le
commissaire ou langue officielle va
avoir plus dedans pour faire appliquer
la loi on parle d'imposer des amandes
c'est un aspect qu'on a un peu oublié de
la loi mais on disait effectivement à
Air Canada notamment avec ça et le
français reste toujours les pieds nos
pieds derrière Canada puis on se rend
compte que année après année on le règle
jamais puis pour revenir un peu à la
rémunération monsieur Rousseau tant
qu'on traite pas le français comme étant
une compétence essentielle au même titre
que toutes les autres compétences qu'on
donne entre PDG on aura ce problème là
alors c'est toujours relié au second
rang la question du français c'est vu
comme étant oui c'est un atout
nécessaire intéressant et tout ce que
vous voulez mais c'est jamais pro au
sérieux et puis je pense que vendredi il
va falloir dire non c'était au même
titre que avoir des bonnes connaissances
de gestion des connaissances financières
et autres et on a naviation aéronautique
mais le Français devrait être
Christian conclusion rapide là-dessus je
trouve que les francophones on est
souvent très mollasson on dit il faut
qu'il fasse des efforts pour apprendre
le français on est dans une obligation
de Moyer et non de résultats ça avait
été une énorme affaire le fait que le
président des Canada parlait pas
français pendant plusieurs semaines et
puis si parlent pas français c'est très
humiliant pour le Québec et pour le
français c'est le spi quoi de l'aragance
là-dedans et moi ce que je suggère il
pourrait pas comparer devant une
commission fédérale pour qu'on le sache
s'il parle français ou pas c'est ça la
clé là il est censé l'engagement de
comparer quand on convoque puisqu'on
l'entende si parle pas français qu'on le
débarque
je vous fais entendre oui merci
Christian je vous fais entendre
Eric Duhem qui veut lancer une pétition
pour demander au Québec de ne plus
financer indirectement ou directement ce
qui finance plutôt indirectement dans la
bibliothèque des drag queen qui
viendraient lire des contes je vous fais
entendre le chef du Parti conservateur
du Québec
je pose problème avec la motion qui a
été présenté par Québec solidaire c'est
les mots exposés les enfants au drive
Queen et dire que ça va faire du Québec
un exemple en matière d'inclusion ou et
d'égalité c'est là où je pense que ça
déborde et c'est là où ça passe pas le
gouvernement n'a pas à décider s'il veut
ou non exposer les enfants au drag queen
c'est l'autorité parentale qui devrait
être décidée
alors voilà
Michel C et Christian Dufour
vous êtes là Christian je pense qu'on a
un problème avec la connexion de
Geneviève Tellier mais Michel C
et qu'est-ce que votre conclusion c'est
un débat un autre débat un peu
surréaliste
oui
actuellement aux États-Unis la droite
américaine la droite dure de gouverneur
de santé déjà comme ça ça va être très
fort la théorie des gens avec tout ça
monsieur dum a besoin d'exposer il a
besoin de faire parler de lui il peut
pas entrer un centre national comme il
veut alors il y a pris cette ce moyen là
je doute que ce soit très bon je doute
aussi que les enfants en moyenne drag
queen ne comprennent pas qu'il s'agit
quelqu'un qui se déguise de la même
façon quelqu'un j'étais petit et que
j'écoutais La Boîte à Surprise il y
avait plein de de gens qui étaient
déguisés là-dedans puis j'avais compris
que ça des comédiens qui étaient
déguisés pour quand même pas penser que
là il va avoir une grande une grande
tentative de perversion des mers c'est
des c'est quelqu'un qui doit dans des
bibliothèques pour faire la promotion de
la lecture et non pas
à minuit de dragon
ça sort donc au café qui vous parle ça
c'est pas c'est pas une bibliothèque ça
va il y a deux choses là-dedans c'est
vrai que pour Éric Zem c'est une façon
de faire parler de son parti que les
médias ont complètement abandonné depuis
quelques mois alors qui ont obtenu quand
même pas mal de suffrage des gens et ça
marche parce qu'on en parle ce soir au
panel mais il y a un sujet j'écoutais
aujourd'hui tous les combattants au
Québec qui disait c'est juste par
rapport à politique bon les drag queen
c'est assez sympathique c'est pas des
transsexuels transgenres il faut il faut
le rappeler c'est des gens qui donnent
des bons spectacles donc ils peuvent
raconter de bons comptes aux enfants
mais il peut avoir la tentation du
militantisme pour des idéologies comme
la théorie des genres qui sont très
critiqués et critiquables des sujets
comme est-ce que l'étrangères ne
prennent pas trop de place dans le débat
public ça c'est un vrai sujet il y a des
gens qui trouvent ça aussi donc c'est
délicat je suis pas sûr comme dit Michel
est-ce que c'est vraiment gagnant mais
il y a un vrai sujet jusqu'à quel point
jusqu'où il faut aller sur ces termes-là
faut pas être fait pour avoir une
militantisme aussi là-dedans mais
jusqu'ici en tout cas il y a aucun cas
où on a rapporté autre chose que des
lectures de contes d'enfants dans des
bibliothèques plutôt gentilles et là
Geneviève votre vos impressions
mais ce que moi je vois un peu dans
l'histoire de Eric durbaine c'est ça va
peut-être être mouillé c'est à dire que
oui lui il veut lancer une grande
pétition puis avoir beaucoup de normes
mais finalement si je regarde ce qui se
passe au Québec j'ai pas l'impression
que un mouvement qui l'a pue vraiment
puis effectivement on trouve ça plutôt
bon enfant d'avoir des personnages
colorés qui racontent des histoires dans
les écoles c'est tout le temps qu'on a
je vous dis à brutement bonsoir et merci
à très bientôt au revoir au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI